what would you say is the ideal length
of a short film that's it's hard I mean
I everybody just has like 15 minutes and
yeah no because I mean we have films are
in five minutes seven minutes that are
like incredible that films there any
number of lengths that are or even in
the 20s and 30 minutes that are
incredible films the film is great and
again I was going back to this if the
film if it's set out nobody give us 30
minutes for us to 30 minutes or under so
you know some other like the Academy is
is longer I think it's 40 minutes if a
film this is it I say that's right way
if it's it it's the story is if it's
complete the film's you know done very
well with the production value and shot
very very well the actors are great
stories good stories told that you know
the essentially goals reached the story
they want to tell has been told in a
very very strong manner then it doesn't
matter the length we look at it like
that I mean I don't want to I don't want
to program looking at something that's
30 minutes a oh well you know that's
really good but it's it's long you know
it's just the 30 minutes if we feel the
film it holds up against any other film
especially for its category we have to
program that film over others first we
don't want to like bump that film out
because well you know what it's it's too
long no granted it does take into effect
sometimes that films that are are on the
cusp whether it's they got great a
little lower and it's hard to get in and
you only this much time yeah we have to
program like a film or two that's 15
minutes in length as opposed to 30
minutes so you can't fit it in that
program you know say for instance we
have a drama you know in the drama
category and it's a and we already have
an hour and a half programmed and they
only have 15 minutes left the program
for that that's lie then yes if a film
is rated equally with another film that
can wait you know then we can't fit it
just doesn't fit so we'll have to push
that aside and you might not make it in
but uh you know it's it's it's again I
feel like if the story story and acting
or two things I feel are very important
you know that films were watching if the
actors aren't strong were it's not
holding up your story's falling apart I
mean you know you you know lose
attention and the film will just knit
will not be will not be very good and
story-wise stories of women as well
you know you people that have an idea
that looks good and Shotwell you like
this looks great
and then the story doesn't take you
anywhere and it just kind of lags see me
be a seven minute film but it feels like
it's thirty minutes and and and the
action doesn't move forward and it isn't
it's not telling the story you feel it
was intended it's tell them so that's
you know then there you go so the
runtime kind of doesn't matter you know
it's like it's more about there's a
story itself in the film itself and the
runtime so I kind of look at did the
quality really the quality of film again
is it more important if you like if you
feel like a story was told well for the
means they had and all that and that's
that's most important but the general
sense for does help to have shorter
films I'm feeling really good and it's
short that's gonna be easier program
clearly there's gonna be space for it
and it's gonna be easier to slide in the
program so you know yeah is that was
similar for documentary films
yeah yeah I mean it's somewhat you have
someone but doctors tend to run longer
you know most of the docs beginner are
longer in length you know they're
usually not too short because obviously
diving into a have your subject matter
maybe we're trying to tell a story about
a situation and documentary in nature
can't be too short right I mean you know
if you try and really get into a story
and getting to know some was live life
or lives or you know if it's a situation
about you know some some things say you
know the factory workers getting laid
off in the town and how it affects the
town get to get into the story and
really get to meet the people to really
understand the scope so those films are
generally longer so that that is a
programming challenge because we only
usually have two programs max for
documentaries sometimes even one so
that's what two hours or four hours to
fill and that's it so if you have five
films they're thirty minutes in length
that's already you fill you've filled in
time we'll party so that makes it
challenging on that front but those ones
have to be that way
I mean again documentaries you know a
different nature so they kind of have to
be a little bit longer you know
gentlemen
the dogs have seen
you